welcome to council of geeks my name is
nathaniel and i'm joined by Ryan Daley
and we're going to be talking some of
the latest geeky trailers to come out
not Star Wars because I gave my thoughts
on that one before no we're going to go
to the other end of the spectrum and
we're going to talk Batman V Superman
and Fantastic Four and starting with the
latest offering from DC their first
teaser to come out thoughts I know a lot
of people were excited about this teaser
for batman vs superman dawn of justice I
was not excited for it were you know it
sounded like they were doubling down on
a lot of what I didn't like about Man of
Steel the darkness the tone the
presentation of Superman as something to
be feared and hated and shunned by the
people of Earth that's not the Superman
that I particularly care for seeing that
reinforced ad nauseam in this teaser
just turned me off completely yeah and
the question that I kept coming out back
with was if Superman is the character
that is hated and feared in this
universe what does that leave for Batman
because that's that man stick and these
characters when they work it's because
they're polar opposite and they bring
out what is special in each other the
sense of hope and aspiration versus the
sense of dread and despair and I just
get the dread and the despair from both
sigh both sigh yeah front center is the
sort of setting up to throw down right
between these two characters and that
just strikes me as a really weird thing
to sell the movie on I mean on the one
hand yes it's the title but we know
Justice League is coming so we know they
will eventually work together so I mean
I furthest this this throat out could
happen would be maybe mid way through
act 2 of this film they'll reconciling
the go on to fight a bigger evil you
know that's what's going to happen so
selling this movie on Batman and
Superman fighting that's a little bit
like selling the first of
in jerz movie on the fight between Iron
Man and Thor right right that was that
was a memorable part people knew about
that part going into the film it was it
it was in the marketing they show
glimpses but they weren't they weren't
like here come and see this this is the
reason to see this movie because it was
one small part of something much bigger
yeah I wasn't even thinking about but if
you just took that title card and
replace the V with a slash mark or a
plus symbol or anything answer or sand
for crying out loud thank you yeah
anything that just says batman and
superman you're still going to get the
same group of people you're still going
to attract the same audience i think
what you sell this on is if seeing them
in the same movie for the first time
it's seeing them together on screen what
we see a Ben Affleck especially when
he's in the student is very reminiscent
of the dark knight returns the Frank
Miller and what we see if sort of the
setup of the fight is very much in that
vein to he's got that he's got the
powered armor Snyder's action very
clearly pulling heavily from the dark
knight returns but I don't think he's
pulling the right things or he's pulling
from the dark knight returns at the
wrong time the problem is the context or
lack thereof when you think about the
context of the dark knight returns it
was a story about Superman and Batman at
the end of their career yeah and it was
about these two guys and actually the
superman/batman fight was very a very
small part of the dark knight returns
but it was still about these characters
who had been friends for a long time
they broke up and they're coming back
together as enemies on the opposite side
of a philosophical and political
ideology we're not getting that in the
context of the end of their careers for
this film we're no yeah yeah you're
having them fight right at right out the
gate when they first meet he just so you
lose all the weight and all the history
of what made that a momentous showdown
you know oddly you know when you just
made me think of was the the newest
Ninja Turtles movie because what that
will be did which infuriated me was
because it was a reboot there was
obviously no history for it to pull room
but it tried to have moments that only
would have worked if it had history like
it tried to have the fight between
splinter and shredder be this big
momentous event
but within the context of the film
itself these two had never encountered
each other before ever so it's like
they're banking on the pop culture
awareness of these two characters to
give weight so that they won't have to
in the film itself I have a very strong
feeling I'm going to come away with this
movie angry at it for the same reason
that I was angry at the second Fantastic
Four movie amazing spider-man 2 and the
the second and third Hobbit movies which
is that what I saw the first one in all
three of those cases I had issues but I
made certain allowances because I saw
what they were going for and I saw the
potential I saw what they were trying to
do here's what didn't work I'll give you
the benefit of the doubt please make
corrections so when everyone went okay
we'll come back again please fix these
things but then the sequels did the
exact same thing that was done before
with no Corrections and no adjustments
now you've pissed me off because you've
taken my benefit of the doubt and just
gone no we're doing the same thing it's
a sequel to Man of Steel sure I mean
let's let's be honest and what is the
standard pattern when you do series the
second one is the dark one so when your
first one is already so devoid of color
and life and fun I it's just being
punched in the face no both ddc do you
remember fun Shirley Fox knows how to
make a fun superhero well you'd think so
but you know for all the complaining i
just made about Batman V Superman I will
take that trailer over the Fantastic
Four second trailer that has come out so
the first teaser it looks like eight it
looked like the teaser for interstellar
yeah and prometheus well the it looks
like every other teaser that I have seen
of this sort of genre and the new
trailer didn't show me anything
different I don't look at this teaser
and or this trailer and say that's a
fantastic for that I want to see it's
not well it doesn't feel like the
Fantastic Four at all because that
they're very much going with aside from
the the interstellar sci-fi fairly
generic feel the trailer what
we start to get into it a little bit
more than things that are unique to
these characters immediately we get the
I want to help my friends I want to cure
them is what you want to cure them you
guys have the classic set of oh my god i
want that that's so cool powers even Ben
Grimm is the thing at least in the
comics he takes it pretty well it kind
of goes out what are you gonna do
working it will it touches a monster in
the face I don't think anybody smiles in
this entire trow I think we get like 10
qward half grin out of Reed Richards but
there's not a single smile on Johnny
Storm of all people though the one tiny
glimmer of light that I got from the
teaser was there are a few images when
we see the Human Torch fully engulfed in
flame we're hid beneath the sort of
white hot flames we see the body that
looks just encased in red just the color
red in a vaguely humanoid form and that
looks like an old comic from the 60s or
that 80's either from john byrne or jack
kirby and that was like oh that that was
right that looks exactly like i want the
human torch to look but nothing else
about what I saw from Michael B Jordan
was the way I want Johnny Storm to act
yeah and I got that from everybody we
get a lot of exposition and dialects are
voicing over explaining the situation
from older scientists or yeah military
figures that basically have to be the
voice of exposition and science and
authority so that our main character
Reed doesn't come off as a know-it-all
nerd which was exactly what he is ah so
the thing is he should be the leader you
also need that sense of the family
dynamic yeah and for that family dynamic
he's got to be a little bit older and a
little bit more mature than miles teller
they want to make him this child prodigy
because they want 18 year olds to go to
this movie and enjoy her 13 year old
early and the other thing about this
trail especially versus the the Batman V
Superman is that the Batman V Superman
trailer was consistent it had a had a
party line that had a plan it knew what
it was it knew what it was selling I
don't like what it's selling
but it's it's gotta focus it's got a
clear mission fantastic four seams
embarrassed by the fact that it's a
superhero movie because about two-thirds
of the way in kind of out of nowhere if
we get we should use our powers to help
people oh and doom is coming is like
what so it's just tacked on at the end
oh by the way they're kind of
superheroes and there's a villain
al-azhar move on from that in the early
and mid 2000s there were a lot of goofy
superhero movies well the fed the
fantastic four films the first two are
solid examples of that and there were a
lot of others that were goofy and tried
to be fun and tried to have fun with the
source material and failed for other
reasons you have quality but I think you
have something like the success of
Batman Begins and then the monster
success of the Dark Knight that followed
it and a lot of studios took the lesson
from that that if we take these movies
super seriously the audience will take
them seriously and the audience will
come in droves completely failing to
take into account at least you can
ground him because he doesn't have her
because power some of his villains do
but you don't have to use them if you
don't want and you can ground his world
when you're dealing with a guy who can
stretch his limbs and a woman who can
turn invisible a guy who can fly while
he's on fire and a talking rock you're
not dealing in something that is meant
to be grounded right and I think the
problems with things like man of steel
and the dark knight rises even the
amazing spider-man movies to a certain
extent I think tried to come off as more
melodramatic and tonally dark and just
ended up becoming depressing and losing
the sense of fun and joy of what these
characters represent I think the
audiences have gone the way of the
Disney and Marvel model which is coming
have fun it would be awesome to be like
this like yeah what's the we would
rather be Iron Man than Batman because
iron man gets to enjoy his life what did
you think of the thing
when I saw the images I thought maybe a
little better emotion and it doesn't it
looks worse I didn't recognize it it
looks like a rock monster that might
have been in the hobbit it had no
personality to it yeah it was it was
just this lumbering pile of rocks well
how much personality do we get from the
characters in this teaser let me go to
the next character what do you remember
about the invisible woman from this
teaser she turned invisible at one point
she badd hate flirted with Reed Richards
once that that's all I've got she was
invisible she has been a licensed in the
season like I cannot find it in me to to
support this movie I know I want to like
it I don't want to see Batman vs
Superman either I have a feeling that i
will just because that's harder to turn
away from it's been a long time since
I've gotten drunk and going to see a
movie that might require some shots by
right we have to revive that custom well
you know what just take a breath and
remind yourself Star Wars Star Wars oh
good time there we go so I guess we'll
wrap up on that note and folks you find
you a lot of places you got a mess a
podcast these days don't try to do I'm
going crazy with the podcasts now first
off you can find my Star Wars podcast
check out the blogger page dead buffin
spies blogspot com and from there you
can find the dead buffin spies podcast
on itunes i also have a blog devoted to
the DC Comics heroin Black Canary you
can find that at Black Canary fan
blogspot com and the blog and podcast
associated with it is flowers and
fishnets in Black Canary podcast I've
also got a third podcast in the works
but that's not come until later in the
summer alright busy man well thank you
very much for joining me and what were
your thoughts on these two trailers that
came out whatever it is drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
until next time this council is a jerk